[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mardi 18 avril
dernière ligne droite pour la campagne
présidentielle les militants des
différents candidats se mobilisent pour
tenter de convaincre les indécis
c'était le cas notamment sur le marché
de versailles dimanche reportage à
suivre
faire du sport à plusieurs voilà une
source de motivation une bonne idée qui
peut se révéler compliqué à organiser
parfois un problème en passe d'être
résolue et ce grâce à une nouvelle
application lancée par deux nuits en
cours toi with the sport permet de
mettre en relation des sportifs d'un
même territoire
enfin comme tous les mardis dans ce
journal portrait d'un acteur ou d'une
actrice de la vie locale cette semaine
rencontre avec la nouvelle miss paris
originaire des yvelines
audrey brook après son titre la jeune
femme vous le découvrirez soit désormais
faire carrière dans le mannequinat des
images de sport pour débuter ce journal
et les bonnes performances des yvelinois
aux championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste qui se tenait à hong kong le
trappistes benjamin thomas a remporté
notamment deux médailles d'or de son
côté ligne montrent un françois pervis
n'est pas en reste le pistard de 32 ans
a remporté une médaille d'or sur le
kilomètre son quatrième titre mondial
dans cette discipline et le bronze en
vitesse aussi par équipes pour lui est
la france grâce notamment à ses bonnes
performances termine deuxième au tableau
des médailles derrière l'australie avec
cinq médailles dont trois en or et pour
eux aussi
tout se joue dans le sprint final avec
ses intentions de vote
ultra serré avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle dans cinq
jours elle les militants et les soutiens
des candidats sont mobilisés pour tenter
de convaincre les indécis devant les
gars devant les magasins mais aussi sur
les marchés comme à versailles dimanche
les troupes étaient très motivés comme
on peut le constater
anne laure l'anguille et yves hub stand
berger plus que sept jours pour
s'imposer dans la campagne à versailles
ce dimanche matin les militants peu
mythix affaire a tenté de convaincre les
passants les plus visibles sont les
supporters de françois fillon avec leurs
tee shirt bleu on accélère l'as laissé
les derniers jours donc des derniers
jours pour convaincre les indécis on a
eu une une campagne très très atypique
donc on a encore beaucoup d'électeurs
indécis
l'enjeu tout faire pour que les
électeurs de françois fillon se
mobilisent lors du premier tour dimanche
prochain
on voit bien que françois fillon est en
train de remonter on voit que il arrive
à mobiliser de manière très large et
quand je dis très large chez aussi bien
sur le terrain donc on voit aujourd'hui
au marché de versailles on est très très
nombreux à tracter pour lui et c'est ça
qui va fonctionner c'est ça qui va payer
ce travail de terrain tout aussi
enthousiaste les électeurs du parti
l'est républicain croit à la victoire de
leur candidat
les costumes et toutes les affaires ne
fillon n'en a rien à faire fillon c'est
le seul qui est capable de redresser le
pays
mais le discours n'est pas homogène ici
à versailles les candidats en bas de
l'échelle dans les sondages restent
séduisants pour une frange de la
population
je suis assez intéressé par les idées
des petits candidats
ils sont beaucoup plus près des réalités
que nos ténors politiques
un discours que tente de faire passer
les militants de françois asselineau un
des six candidats prévus sous la barre
des 5%
je pense que ça marche très bien on le
voit bien en ça marche très très bien
c'est sûr il y en a quelques-uns qui
s'interrogent ils se posent des
questions qui auraient voté mais savent
pas y avait de plus en plus intérêt pour
françois séners en tous les cas jamais
la dernière semaine d'une campagne
présidentielle n'aura été aussi
incertaine et décisive
politique toujours est cette élection
présidentielle une centaine de militants
du mouvement en marche des manuels
macron se sont rassemblés pour une
réunion publique à trappes
il y a quelques jours le choix de la
ville n'est évidemment pas anodin
puisque trappe et le fief électoral de
benoît hamon le candidat socialiste
le choix de la thématique aussi
l'économie sociale et solidaire
reportage de nicolas d'andré emmanuel
macron sur les terres du député benoît
hamon pour l'un des derniers meetings
ses militants se sont réunis à trappes
en fin de semaine dernière
comme trapel et l'emblématique dans
notre projet parce que elle symbolise
justement tout tout ce dynamisme qu'on
retrouve au sein des populations qu'on
retrouve au sein de la société civile
mais qu'on ne ressent pas quand on
regarde les résultats thématique de la
soirée l'économie sociale et solidaire
une politique cher à benoît hamon qui a
porté une loi sur le sujet loi
promulguée le 31 juillet 2014
on va les riffs et un destin à l'aider à
la mitterrand vous n'avez pas le
monopole du coeur ou benoît hamon n'a
pas le monopole de la ss est en fait
dans le rôle de porte parole à deux le
ss je suis a amené à aller dans tous les
territoires pour parler de ces
problématiques qui sont au coeur du
projet de des maillots l'ain compte dans
la salle des soutiens de benoît hamon
sont venus constater la mobilisation des
trappistes derrière emmanuel macron la
plupart des militants du mouvement en
marche présents ce soir là sont venus du
nord des yvelines je sais quel est
l'enjeu pour en marche pour conquérir
cette ville on sait bien qu'elle ait le
député de ce territoire
je ne rentrerai pas dans les détails
mais pour moi c'est un enjeu énorme de
marché dans cette ville il a un projet
qui est tourner également vers les
personnes qui habitent dans des
quartiers qui sont dits défavorisés
il a tout ce qu'il faut dans son
programme pour permettre à ces personnes
de se sortir de leurs de leur misère
sociale de le mieux les accompagner
donc il est important de venir sur le
terrain pour montrer l'attachement de
d'emmanuel macron as population dernière
ligne droite pour les militants et binoy
avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce dimanche 23 avril
on change d'actualité mon reste attrape
le week-end dernier était organisé le
mondial d'improvisation juniors quatre
équipes participer à l'événement et pour
cette troisième édition ce sont les
jeunes français qui se sont imposés en
finale face au québécois de justesse 7 à
6 écoutez à ce propos le responsable du
secteur improvisation de déclic et
théâtre la compagnie qui a organisé ce
mondial et ça s'est super bien passé
franchement c'était trop cool là il ya
eu il ya eu des grands moments des
grands moments de fête des grands
moments de plaisir de partage de de fun
du jeu il ya eu de l'impro enfin je ne
sais pas comment je peux le définir mais
si je dois essayer de résumer ce qui
s'est passé ça a été vraiment un vrai
carrefour de la culture de
l'improvisation théâtrale en fête et du
match d'improvisation parce que chacun
est venu avec un petit peu ses manières
de faire et où ils sont adaptés à ce
qu'on nous propose la trappe
et sachez qu'un retour détaillé et
complet de la compétition vous sera
proposé dans le 7-8 culture présentée
par mélanie peau qui ce mercredi soir
première diffusion donc demain soir à
19h45
à quelques semaines de l'été du maillot
de bain et de la plage certains à pense
peut-être à faire du sport activement
problème il est très souvent compliqué
de se motiver
seule une application mobile pour faire
du sport à plusieurs vient d'être lancée
ce week end
derrière le projet deux habitants de
guyancourt très ambitieux leur
application est d'ores et déjà
disponible
regardez
démonstrations de danses et cocktails à
gogo le tout dans une ambiance de soi
reid
les créateurs de l'application with his
portes n'ont pas fait les choses à
moitié pour son lancement
yannick herren l'un des fondateurs de
l'entreprise explique comment ça marche
c'est une application mobile qui me
permettrait de trouver un partenaire
sportif et malheureusement je n'ai rien
trouvé
et c'est de ce moment là je me suis dit
je vais créer applications sportives tu
as me permettent de trouver un
partenaire sportif autour de moi à côté
de chez moi qu'on pratique et peu
importe le sport que je veux dans un
premier temps with portes sera testé en
ile de france et proposera tous les
types de sports pour lesquels il y aura
des recherches de partenaires
ce soir là toute l'assemblée a
téléchargé l'appli est même commencé à
l'utiliser report cela de mon téléphone
car l'emploi banque de demain je vais
tuer pour un sport d'ailleurs demain il
ya une course à saveurs d'ailleurs je
serai son usage reste gratuit pour les
particuliers
en revanche côté professionnel du sport
il faut conclure un partenariat avec
l'application pour pouvoir y figurer
salle de sport associations et clubs
sportifs semblent t'intéresser cheka
forme
on recherche beaucoup les des
particuliers comme ça qu'ils nous aident
à justement avoir plus de clients chez
nous donc ça peut nous rapporter
vraiment beaucoup de beaucoup de
potentiel
les entrepreneurs vise 10 mille
utilisateurs d'ici à trois mois dans le
département mais aussi ailleurs en
france
une fois ce palier at il espère toucher
d'autres clients comme les seniors
[Musique]
notre portrait de la semaine est
consacrée à la nouvelle miss paris du
concours miss planète elle est
yvelinoise originaire des essarts le roi
et s'appelle audrey brook la jeune femme
a été à sa créée en octobre dernier
depuis elle poursuit son rêve devenir
mannequin une rencontre et un portrait
signé osman un vendeur d et nicolas
d'andré chaque semaine audrey brook
enchaîne cinq ou six séances de sport
pour préserver un physique qui lui a
permis de gagner le titre de miss paris
la jeune femme d'un mètre 70 s'entraîne
sans relâche défi mais quatre ans j'ai
même pratiqué du foot
j'ai joué au foot j'ai fais de
l'athlétisme
donc pour moi c'est essentiel c'est j'ai
fait de la danse également
donc j'ai jamais jamais lâché le sport
c'est vrai que pendant mes études
j'avais un peu plus de mal à être
assidus mais c'est vrai que c'est enfin
bon ça fait partie de mon quotidien
c'est quelqu'un aime et on ne pratique
pas de sport ou que quelqu'un me suis
pas ou on n'aime pas ça c'est même dans
mes amis c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
à comprendre
remarqué lors du salon de l'automobile
alors qu elle était hôtesse
on lui propose de défiler pour l'oréal à
cette époque l'église noise mène encore
des études en alternance et décroche un
master en management spécialisation
marketing
elle décide ensuite de tourner la page
et se lance dans le concours de top
model europe
je suis arrivé dans les deux dernières
sur 6000 candidats qui met participants
au népal ils ont fait un casting dans
toute l'europe
moi j'ai passé le casting le casting à
lille c'est arrivé donc dans l'eure
les dix dernières déjà fait un écart de
trois points donc là ça s'est passé
mars 2013 et ensuite par la suite j'ai
continué donc là je me suis lancé j'ai
des propositions dont des marques de
fitness dont la fête à miami ne s'est
pas concrétisée c'est un peu loin des
masses des fidèles donc là j'ai eu des
salles de sport pour faire leur
publicité donc dans le sport a
essentiellement depuis miss paris
enchaîne les pubs les chroniques radios
les shootings photos encore les clips
comme son apparition dans le clip de
niel scène un artiste r'n'b
j'ai besoin de projets
mais ne fut pas les
même si j'ai encore besoin de moi
à 26 ans se consacre à sa passion elle
est aujourd'hui l'égérie de l'institut
relooking beauté minceur à coignières
pour qui elle enchaîne les séances
photos alors redressé présenter clientes
dans les tout premiers jours où j'ai
ouvert l'institut et puis en discutant
avec elle je me suis rendu compte du
couffin elle m'a dit qu'elle était miss
paris depuis 2016
et puis en discutant on s'est dit que ça
pouvait être bien de faire un
partenariat pour l'ouverture de mon
institut donc audrey me semblait très
sympathique des séances photos
importante pour aude reybrouck il faut
il faut une vision médiatique puisque
bon bah moi on me voit voilà fut
médiatisée mais surtout je suis figée en
photo on peut voir en qui mais là on
voit pas ma vie on voit vraiment l'aude
reybrouck là aujourd'hui celle audrey
brook les langes et donc à la audrey
entre guillemets là non pas la miss mail
à la audrey et là c'est une importance
puisqu'on relais on voit ma vie on voit
aussi les côtés d'audrey donc c'est
important pour les personnes qui me
suivent de voir et d'apprendre à me
connaître également quand je fais du
sport par exemple ou lors d'un shooting
en fin d'année la miss paris 2016 sera
l'ambassadrice de la france au concours
miss planète
on referme ce journal sur ces images de
pâques et la chasse aux oeufs géante
organisée par la ville de coignières
parc de l'après vandry c'était ce
week-end des dizaines d'enfants âgés de
2 à 11 ans avait pour mission de
retrouver en tout 1400 se cacher
objectif chocolat donc pour le plus
grand bonheur de tous des petits comme
des grands comme vous le voyez sur ses
aises images c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le
journal merci de nous avoir suivi tous
nos reportages sont à retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]